Ryan Matthew joins us live outside Puppy
World near Durango and Warm Springs in
the southwest Valley with how you at
home can help
Christian Kirsten it's a dog eat dog
world out there especially for Puppy
World here they're one of two Spring
Valley pet stores that were robbed
within the past two weeks thousands of
dollars were lost but the stores tell us
it's a scene they've seen before
it began here at Sahara pets near Sahara
and Durango Police say these people
caught on security camera broke into the
store on October 24th before 8 in the
morning Flyers at the store show five
dogs were taken worth thousands of
dollars each
then this past Tuesday Puppy World near
Durango and Warm Springs took a hit the
owner telling me these people drilled
the front lock and stole two puppies
with a combined value of seven thousand
dollars he adds in a statement quote
they surveyed it Halloween day and went
to two of my locations and then came
back Tuesday at three o'clock in the
morning driving the same vehicle in same
clothing yeah everybody loves corgis the
Puppy World sales manager Matthew
Baldwin says it's a scene all too common
day or night somebody was you know
loving on a dog I thought but um they
actually picked up their puppy that they
wanted and they took off running out to
the door they had their getaway driver
they hopped in the car run out he says
increased during the holiday season each
year but don't get any easier oh yeah
these are my babies these are my babies
so that's why you know I get very
emotional about it so if somebody wants
to come and do something to one of my
children you know
I I get uh I get very protective
now this is still an ongoing
investigation Metro Police and the store
owner saying they're Limited in what
they can't say right now but the store
owner's telling us extra security now in
place at their stores reporting live
near Warm Springs in Durango Ryan mathey
ages now